all right let's go to jeremiah in los
angeles california i've been with my
wife for 14 years 12 married um found
out
last year that she was kind of having an
affair with somebody at
our local gym here hey let me can i stop
can i stop you right there
yeah sure what does kind of having an
affair mean
well i guess uh to me and i mean uh i'm
i'm thinking of it
as like a physical or uh more of a uh
emotional than a physical so i just say
kinda
okay don't say if there was a violation
of y'all's boundaries don't say kind of
let's just call it what it is okay
yeah yes okay she was having an affair
okay with a with a guy at the gym and uh
it was probably
you know going on for about six months i
kind of had an incling to it
you know before before i found out
officially but
i mean it was just kind of in the back
of my head um
but officially found out last year for
sure that it was going on and so it's
been a year since then
when i found out and just things right
now are rocky
um you know we're we're trying to work
it out well i guess i'm trying to work
it out but really it just seems like a
one-way street with us
you know i'm trying trying everything
here and then
you know i've never reached out to
anybody else besides you know my brother
family stuff like that but uh you know i
saw your program
on youtube and you know i was listening
to it i was like you know what i'm going
to reach out to dr john
and that's where that's where we're at i
appreciate your trust brother
absolutely and it's just important to
acknowledge i know we hear about this
all the time all the time all the time
but this sucks man i'm sorry this
happened to you man
now thank you i appreciate it um so
when you and your wife sat down and
talked about this i don't know if you
sell text messages or you saw she was
sending him photos or something like
that
you find out then you sit down and have
the conversation what was the
conversation like
so conversation was well i i found out
at work um
you know with the text messages actually
from the the guy's wife that she was
seeing um so i got the text messages i
i'm thinking in the back of my head like
no this is this is fake you know i
didn't know the number
i'm just putting it put everything
behind me i'm like nah that's not real
and then they sent the text messages
back and forth and i'm just like oh my
gosh my world just
crashed yeah dude so you talked to your
wife you talked to your wife how does
that go man
yeah your heart's broken you don't even
know what dad is right you're not eating
yeah how'd that conversation go um
for the most part uh i mean i came home
early that day
and i you know i took her by the hand
and my daughter was in the room so i
said you know let's go to the back i got
to ask you something and
you know i was real level-headed cool i
wasn't you know angry or anything i just
i wanted to just
you know hear it from her like is this
for real like i mean i showed her the
text messages and everything and
you know like i told you before i kind
of had an inkling so when i saw those i
just was like oh my god
oh my goodness you know like i can't
believe this right now yeah
so i mean um you know she was very
dismissive about it just like oh no he's
just a friend
you know uh and then after we talked
about a little more it's like other
things start coming out like oh he's my
best friend
i can talk to him a lot and mind you
he's a
stay-at-home dad himself and she's a
stay-at-home mom
which she has been for the last 10 years
so um
you know i i don't know i just was i
just was in shock dr john
yeah yeah yeah rightfully so my heart
was in a thousand pieces i'm over there
trying to pick it up trying to put it
back together and
that's what i feel like i've been doing
the last year and it just doesn't seem
like it's going anywhere
so her first response was denial in a
lie when did she circle up and say
finally admit like yeah i've been seeing
this dude
um i mean i would say probably like a
couple weeks after we had
you know we were having conversations
all the time about it yeah
and you know just you know she just
finally said like one day like you know
like
like he's my best friend like i i just
want to see him all the time and
it just was that was another killer it's
like how do you say that this guy's your
best friend when i'm your husband and
we're supposed to be best friends you
know we're supposed to be the ones
talking all the time
were you all having were you was this a
total shock to you were you all having
problems in your marriage have you all
talked about being distant
in the past no no that's that was
another thing is like we we i always
felt like our relationship was very
close you know we're
you know we're always we're always
honest with each other we're always
talking to each other
and then um you know for this to come
about it just was like i said a total
shocker i just kind of
i just kind of wrap my head around it
honestly yeah man i'm sorry
so so why do you want to stay in this
relationship man
because i love her i mean she's the love
of my life i've been with her for 14
years
we have two beautiful girls together um
and we
we both come from broken marriages yeah
my mom and dad got
divorced when i was in my in it when i
was 18
and she didn't have her dad you know
pretty much most of her life so
um and he still isn't a part of her life
to this day
so when you say she's not invested she
has no interest in and staying
she's she telling you i want to be
divorced
um she's she's brought it up a couple
times but it's never the trigger's never
been pulled on it she's
she's talked about separating you know i
just don't i just don't feel the same
way about you
you know i i feel like we're on two
separate paths and it's like
you know i've always been on the same
path dr john i work you know all the
time to provide for the family
you know that's my role as a man i feel
like you know i came from that type of
background
and you know i i don't know if it's some
type of resentment she holds towards me
because i get to leave every day and
leave her with the kids
or what what it is i i i i'm going to
tell you this jeremiah
you're going to make yourself stone
insane trying to get inside her head
and figure out why she's thinking the
way she's thinking
right okay and when we get hurt or we
get scared or we get
out of control it's that's a temptation
man it's
getting uh i know why they did that
because of x man you're gonna make
yourself nuts
you know what i mean and there's
probably a thousand different things and
what i'll tell you
is it's a fool's errand you're never
gonna fully get there
and you're just gonna you're gonna drive
yourself mad so
here's the ah man i i'm
yeah i'm going to here's the thing you
can't change her mind
right she's an adult and she's going to
have to make that decision
um what this tension is and what this
back and forth is and what this
uh yeah i don't know on her end
and um the tension you feel in your own
house
walking around eggshells in your own
house and it my guess is it probably
vacillates between this is my damn house
i'm gonna be who i want to be
and then also you're on eggshells
because you want to make her mad and
then you're starting to feel yourself
lose it right yeah exactly um
and then you talk to yourself you have
these pep talks on the way home your
heart rate gets up
you get kind of fired up about it and
then that the next day you're gonna
bring flowers and you're just gonna
start spinning yourself out
so there's the important part of the
just y'all being adults right and i know
i'm talking this is a pot talking to
kettle here
but two adults have got to get in a room
and have this conversation
but right there's a reason underneath
that
well you need to have this conversation
because i need to have this conversation
right
you just need to make some decisions but
i'm going to tell you right now
you are not passively influencing your
daughters you are
affirmatively hurting them okay okay
they are absorbing this tension
they are absorbing your back and forth
your wife's indifference
whatever she's saying about you when
you're not there her staring at her
phone all day while they're in her
presence or not
all of that stuff they're absorbing and
here's the deal brother
they are in their little minds how old
are they
uh ten and six oh gosh yeah and they're
10 and six year old that's about the age
of my kids
every every interaction with their
parents
every bit of tension they are absorbing
as their fault and they're gonna spend
their life trying to fix it
not a good thing no it's not all of that
tension
all of that ambiguity frustration they
absorb
and sometimes kids try to solve that
through being perfect
sometimes kids solve that through
addiction they solve that through one
relationship after another after another
they solve that through the the they
go on religious walkabouts whatever that
may be but they spend their life chasing
that down
very similar situation you find yourself
in right
yeah and definitely all that to say is
this you have
got to have a hard conversation
in a in a respectful kind dignified way
because there is a chance that your wife
is a terrible terrible
wife and an extraordinary mom she might
be a great mom to these girls
she might does she love those kids oh
yeah she does she's a great mother i'll
i'll never
never take that away from her she's the
she's the best mom because
well just like i said to the first
caller man we need more guys like you in
the world
i appreciate your heart here my guess is
this is probably a long time coming
and whether you missed it or whether
your wife was highly deceptive
usually it's a it's a it's both and
something sneaks up on people or
something doesn't sneak up on people
whatever happens to me i need you to go
to your wife
and say listen for the sake of our
daughters they're absorbing this
this is re writing in their hearts what
relationships look like what
relationships
feel like and they are taking all of
this tension on their hearts
we can't do that to our daughters we've
got to make some decisions in this house
and i love you i want to be your husband
i'll go to the ends of the earth to
figure out how to make this work
um please don't give up on us let's go
get a marriage therapist let's go get
all let's go all in
right and and let her make a decision
yeah and i know that's a scary thing
because there's a reality that she's
going to say i'm opting for not you
and that's very scary right it is
very yeah that's heartbreaking that's
uh um yeah that's all in man
and it sounds like she
does she care about you she says she
does
okay obviously i mean behavior i mean
the
the affair nonetheless is she still in
touch with this dude are they still
interacting talking all the time
no they're not talking at all actually
the day after i found out we went and
changed her phone number and uh and all
that kind of stuff so she said she
hasn't been in contact with him at all
um since then um also too if i could
just mention it
like with our uh our sleeping
arrangements and stuff she's out on the
couch
okay i'm in the bed by myself um you
know
intimacy is out of out of nothing we're
not
none of that's going on when's the last
time y'all when's the last time you all
slept together
um like slept together or sexually
sexually yeah um
it's probably been about like a month
and a week
okay something like that okay um
when's the last time you sat down and
said we just need to have a
grown-up intimate direct conversation
with one another
just that just actually the other day
honestly how'd it go
um you know it went better than i
thought okay um
i i sat down i talked to her i let her
know that i was
i was in contact with you guys with your
show sure and i let her know that
wednesday i'm i'm gonna be talking to
you know uh dr john um he's a counselor
stuff like that so i let her know that
i'm reaching out there
to to try and make this work sure have
you all gone to see gone to see a
marriage therapist have y'all gone she
won't go
no she won't go we've had that
conversation she's like what are they
gonna tell us and i was like well
they'll tell us what we need to do
yeah you know and it's like that's why i
was saying it's like a one-way street
with this relationship it seems like
right now it's like i want to reach out
i want to save it
but it just doesn't seem like she
doesn't want that she doesn't want to
save it
does she want you to be the bad guy here
does she want you to be the guy that
breaks it off why what's keeping her
from walking out the door
that's what i'm saying i don't know and
i think that's what she wants is for me
to make the decision i said you know
what no this is your decision
i am not making the decision because i
don't want to make that decision i don't
want to leave the relationship i want to
be with you i love you
yeah you know and and i don't know i i
i think she's waiting for that that's
maybe that's why she's you know
not we're not sexually active anymore
maybe she's holding out on me for that
reason i don't i have no idea
uh see again don't get in her head man
okay we're gonna make yourself bananas
um there's a thousand different reasons
why intimacy happens and doesn't happen
and all that
um i'd love to talk to her if she'll
call the show i'd love to love to talk
to her to get her
what's going on in her heart and mind if
she would
but all it to say is this if she won't
have
an adult conversation and she did if she
won't make an adult decision
yeah for you for herself
you'll have to make some decisions for
your daughters okay yeah sooner
rather than later and my hope hope hope
i
again man i'm the most naively
optimistic guy on the planet and i'm not
naive about it i just
i've seen people come back from so many
different brinks
come over so many obstacles because they
fight and they claw and they say
i'm not giving up on this thing i
thought this marriage was an
ash and we're gonna we're gonna redraw
we're gonna rebuild it and we're gonna
create something better and new and
different it's not gonna be the old
thing that we just reconstruct we're
gonna do something remarkable
i've seen it over and over and over i've
had moments in my marriage dude that i
was like oh man things going down it's
going down it's going down
and yeah we hung on and we rebuilt
something new we're still rebuilding
something new
and i think every marriage is
continually rebuilding and rebuilding
and adding and growing
i i've got high hopes for you man but i
do as well but my house are very high
she's got to um she's y'all got to make
a decision sooner rather than later for
those girls
um so here's my challenge to you do what
i just said sit down
and have that hard conversation on
behalf of your daughters on behalf of
you on behalf of her she's killing
herself man
she's got to make a decision and you can
let her know equivalently i will not end
this marriage
period and but we've got to fix this i
want you back
and sleep in bed with me i want you to
we go to marriage counselor you know
what they're going to give you tools
they're going to help you have hard
conversations with one another
tell the truth with one another be open
you may hear things about i promise
you will hear things about you over the
last decade that you don't like
that you didn't even know you were doing
but you're gonna hear a man that's what
a marriage counselor will do to give her
a place to be fully honest and open with
you um
and there'll be a referee there but also
someone's going to teach you
a teacher is going to give you guys some
tools you can work on and rebuild this
thing from the floor up
but those little girls are hanging in
the balance man they're hanging in that
tension and they're absorbing every
second of it man
so the last thing is man i'd love her to
call the show we will
i will move her to the front of the line
if she'll call the show and um or shoot
me an email i'll go to johndeloney.com
show let her know that um she's
jeremiah's wife and we'll move her to
the front of the show i'd love to hear
her perspective on this she's probably
not going to but
um i'd love to hear from her but man
we're thinking about you
and let me know how that conversation
goes let me know where that final
decision is shoot me a note back
and we'll let the listeners know how
things played out
don't give in to despair jeremiah don't
give in to
treating her less than with dignity and
respect because at the end of the day
that's just going to bring
you down and drown you so you've
it sounds like you've taken the high
road on this thing continue to even if
you get the worst of worst news that
she's moving out and the things over
continue to think about those girls
continue to think about what you can
bring to the table as a person of
integrity and dignity
and treat your wife with respect
regardless of how this thing plays out
she's still the mother of your kids i
hate that man